so we are creating a whole emotional
wellness ecosystem a one-stop shop
for everything emotional wellness and we
are doing it without the
use of drugs alcohol or marijuana
[Music]
anita kumari thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you
i'm doing a wonderful thank you for
inviting me i'm honored to be here
well i'm always excited to talk about
happiness and i have a feeling that
we're going to talk about happiness
over the next 20 minutes or so because
if you've had a fabulous career with so
many wonderful companies as a senior
a human resource right you were at at
kaiser and google and verifone and
different other companies that we won't
go into detail here but then you've
transitioned
into happiness and mental health and
you've written a book find your happy
which you've just shown me a second ago
maybe you can show it again in a second
uh beautiful and one of the things you
told me that you're really passionate
about is the space of mental health and
limiting beliefs and how to go beyond
those limiting beliefs
so anita enough from me i want to hear
about you a little bit and about your
journey
yeah so i used to be in a high-tech
corporate career throughout my life
and then life threw me a few curveballs
and i had to learn how to
throw aces and not give in and that was
the point in my life when i
started going into emotional development
and self-growth and
started doing courses like landmark tony
robbins oprah
deepak chopra go and meditation
and yoga and all that stuff and
because when i was going through stuff i
was in a very abusive relationship at
that point
in my time and because my cultural
background i wasn't willing to leave
even though everyone around me was
telling me to leave like
every weekend like other people used to
say oh friday everyone is happy that
they have a weekend why are you so
scared but i was scared to be
alone in home with him right because i
didn't know what was going to happen
because he had already tried to kill me
like three times and
okay i'm sorry before we move on i i'd
love to hear a little bit more
because obviously the second part of
this journey is going to be a wonderful
one about how you're
empowering other women now and you're
inspiring other women but but as long as
you feel
comfortable i'd love to to understand a
little bit more about
what happened there and and how you and
how you broke free of that
sure so let me give you a little bit of
a background of
how i even ended up with him so because
i'm from india
and i've grown up in a very sheltered
and nice family atmosphere so basically
if someone will say something i would
trust them right
and i met this guy who was my friend and
i was very young and he
told me he will kill himself if i don't
marry him
and now i know that's crazy but that
time i thought he loved me that's why
his uh and i thought anyway i have to
have a arranged marriage why not marry
him because he loves me so much
so i got married pretty young and came
here and
and then i did my mba where where is
this in the world by the way
oh this i met him in india but
we came here as soon as we decided to
get married because my parents wouldn't
approve his parents wouldn't approve
and we were very young wow yeah and i
finished only my undergrad at that time
and i came here and i think for one year
the fairy tale lost it but after that
i joined the job i started getting very
successful and even from my first job
i don't know why people started putting
me with the vps and stuff even though i
was like scared that time right i was
like a very junior person
but someone they saw like leadership
qualities and so every time i would have
a meeting he would try to sabotage it i
started doing mba and got into dean
scholar list and
that was like every time something like
that would happen that
they were time he would get more abusive
and so if you so when you say abusive
just to clarify that
is obviously the emotional abuse and and
the feeling
and the physical abuse both but every
time
once or twice i had gotten like mad that
i'll uh go and tell someone and then he
would start crying and then i would feel
sorry for him so i wouldn't usually tell
someone
but what happened is i'm a very happy
person i started totally
losing myself in the sense i wouldn't
even smile and people who knew us
like who were common from our common
school they used to say
what did you do to her she doesn't even
smile anymore she used to laugh so much
but anyway i didn't think any of it i
just thought if i changed myself more
because he didn't like me doing anything
which got me any recognition so i
stopped writing poetry
i stopped being on stage i stopped uh
pretty much talking to people and i was
got so under confident that if someone
would so much as
say hello to me i would start crying
right and i wouldn't drive on freeways
i wouldn't even like go to a grocery
store alone
and and the people who know me then they
say that i
always used to walk like with my head
down which i don't
didn't realize because i was the one
doing it right and i used to
think of it it's my fault like if i do
this different that difference he might
change
and but nothing changed and then because
i used to go to the my doctor for
everything he did she referred me to a
therapist who told me i should leave
while i still can
in one piece that's what she said she
said you should leave while you still
can in one piece
yes because she said with his demeanor
he can even like break your hands and
legs if you tell him you will leave and
then pretend to take care of him
so but i didn't understand that time so
that was my foray into a mental health
because
so i mean finally i had a miscarriage
because of him and uh
i even was scared if i go into like i
was hiking in the santa cruz mountains
and
took me to like very deserted place
where there was no one and on top of the
hill
like uh he was like getting one of his
moods and
and i was thinking if he pushes me right
now no one will ever know what happened
to me
right and that was my i think wake up
call little bit
and another was a miscarriage and then
i just uh decided to leave and i just
left with like a few clothes and few
shoes but uh um
after i left he was and i took a
restraining order but he was able to
emotionally manipulate me to feel guilty
of leaving him and made me sign a power
of attorney
pretty much he kept everything so anyway
so i started my
life from ground zero edward so just for
just for context you're starting your
life again at ground zero first of all
uh
i i can't even believe what what i'm
hearing and so i'm i'm
extremely inspired by by the next thing
that we're going to talk about
because you took that adversity and
you're in you're traveling that through
to empower other women and other people
around the world but before that explain
give me the context so so when you leave
with
with a bag of clothes and some shoes how
old are you
where are you in the us what are you
doing during that time
yeah so i i was out of a job at that
time so i wouldn't want to leave but it
was so bad that
i could not stay and so i had a friend
who
said okay you can my therapist also told
me don't live alone because he's going
to come after you
so i had a friend so i decided to
they said that i can stay in their house
for a little bit so i just
picked up some clothes i decided to
i went with them and started living
there and
and didn't tell anyone where i was
because otherwise he would come and he
was trying to like get me back but my
therapist told me don't go back because
you won't be alive then
because now he knows that you can leave
right because anytime i would say i will
leave if you do if when he was
misbehaving or abusing then he would say
if you try to leave i'll kill you and
kill myself
so i thought it was that way but the
thing is
um i mean if you have heard of severe
narcissistic
psychotic person i think he was one of
that so
so he knew like see how he can
manipulate me because he knew me from my
childhood i had no support system here
and because i was only allowed to be
friends with his friend's wife kind of
thing
so but still i had some colleagues and
some people who
i think god sent to help me and and then
i found then i joined the job within i
think a few weeks of moving out
and so i started saving money and
meanwhile you know like in
i know in california's community
property i even like my therapist has
referred me an
attorney and i thought i'll hire him but
he found out and he convinced me that
attorneys take all the money so i should
not have any attorney so i
didn't have any attorney and he had two
in the background and so basically he
was able to threaten me and
to like sign up and make me feel guilty
enough for me to give him the power of
attorney
i have to ask the parents back home in
india your community back home in india
are they a part of the picture at this
point are they involved in any way
no they are not because my family is
very simple like if you tell them he did
this he'll say
oh let me let us talk to him he will get
better right because they don't know
anyone can be that bad
that's psychotic and they're too far
away
but honestly so i understand that that
that mindset but i have to because you
know in the last
few months i've been hearing constantly
but there are so many stories that have
come up
of domestic abuse and domestic violence
not just in the u.s but around the world
that you know hearing it firsthand now
from your experience
it just brings back brings up all these
emotions of reading all these
of the all these articles uh so i can't
even imagine what it's like going
through that
you know it was really bad believe me i
didn't even know i will survive that
year because i had never lived alone in
my house
in my life i was in a foreign country
with no support system no money
and uh even after i moved out to that
friend's place
as soon as i found job right so like i
had no furniture i slept on the floor
till i was able to buy my furniture
and i had a friend who gave me one glass
one tumbler one plate
some like because i cook a lot at home
so some rice some lentil like everything
so she was like a angel for me even
though i didn't know her that well
and but she realized it right because
she's an older woman
and so i took me i think a month or
something or more to
get the furniture buy buy something then
gradually buy my utensils now i have
everything and i'm proud to say
it's all my maid it doesn't belong to
anyone else 100
my hard work and and during this course
i kept on doing all the self-development
because you know it takes a long time to
heal
so i wasn't willing to go into any
relationship i wasn't willing to date
anyone i wasn't willing to trust any guy
because of
i wasn't healed right so i'm glad that i
went through all this uh
trainings to really heal and not just
really heal my therapist then started
trying to put me on an antidepressant
and i know the side effects i decided
i'm not going to take it i'll start
every day with
a meditation yoga and some zumba class
or kickboxing like something which
is very like untoward of the person at
that time so that gradually got me out
of my comfort zone
and in order for me to really be able to
even trust or
be like next to a guy again because i
i mean when you are really hurt you are
like basically you think everyone is the
same right even though it's a small
sample
one person so i started taking salsa
lessons where you have to dance with a
guy right
a partner yeah and i love salsa yeah
thank you
me too and dancing is very great i think
that was also so that gradually
got me out of that i would say
out of that fear i mean apart from my
apart from my uh
my self-development and uh
and then i realized so many of my
friends for even if like real things
like this are happening
sometimes they are not able to get out
of it and sometimes
they don't talk about it or they feel
ashamed like i used to feel ashamed
before
now i empowered right with the story but
um
and also i used to like i wouldn't even
dare to like uh dress up
or things like that because always he
would be very very crazy about it right
and then yeah so right now
i feel that all mental issues can be
resolved with
natural mental exercises or
hypnotherapy and psychology and without
medication too i mean of course some
people who are totally extreme then they
need the medication at that time
but most of the things like anxiety
stress worry
panic attacks ocd moodiness
and not feeling enough not feeling loved
those things
are self-esteem they all can be resolved
and like i have resolved when you see
miami a living example from where
if you see my pictures there i look like
15 years older than i look right now
wow yeah so i'd love to me i'd love to
talk about that transition because
now you're doing such wonderful things
with the new startup happiness factor
and and i'll oh we'll say now later but
but you have also opened positions for
interns
that i that i'd love to i'd love to tell
a lot of my friends about because it
sounds like a wonderful opportunity
but you also wrote the book find you
happy talk to me about talking about
this journey
in writing this book and what led to
that yeah so
people knew me as a high-tech hr person
because that was my background
so i changed i wanted them to think of
me as a happiness and emotional wellness
expert
and then people told me oh it will take
one year to write a book i didn't have
one here
because i wanted to create the branding
i said i'll write it in
one month and everyone laughed at me but
when i'm dedicated i'm really dedicated
for one month i slept for four hours i
found
10 or 20 people to interview because i
only wanted to write about
real life stories so i interviewed
someone who killed someone with six
bullets was incarcerated for life but
how meditation changed his life and now
he's
out he has a wife and a kid then i
interviewed someone who had survived
breast cancer and she's also thriving
she's a good friend of mine
then someone who had gone through
debilitating accidents
or very bad divorces so much so like i
have a friend who lost everything in the
divorcee
and still is fighting custody for his
kid and
then people who have gone through abuse
people who have gone through of course
the abuse has some part of my story too
though he doesn't have my name
and then someone who has uh who was
raped when he was eight years old and
he never told anyone and finally i
covered his story and now they found out
that
the same guy under the pretext of
helping those
young kids because they were from very
poor family very like a
big family like 17 18 brothers sisters
parents didn't have enough to feed
in chicago and and that guy used to tell
the parents that i will give these kids
like some
uh work to stash shoe boxes because he
had a shoe shop
and he used to rape them behind them you
know they were raped
and so this actually story has given me
the maximum kudos because many people
write to me
that reading that they don't feel
ashamed and they got the closure
because people feel ashamed right even
if it's not their fault
because and that's what i think the
perpetrators always take advantage of
when you are too gullible and too
innocent and
you believe everything they say right
especially if you don't have a support
system or if you don't know what's going
on
so all the 10 stories in my book are
real stories of real life people
and at the end of the chapter i have
given how
they have overcome and are thriving in
life so why can't you
who have so much going on because many
times when i coach people
one-on-one they say oh it's easy for you
to say because you
never had anything bad they don't know
my background right so they think right
now i look happy so i must have
everything going so good for me all the
time
and so then i wanted them to see that
no not everyone has it going good all
the time the people who are really
successful
are the ones who make the best of what's
happening and come out
learn enough from that experience and
come out of winner
unbelievable wow okay that's uh truly
inspiring
and again that a lot of people can talk
about
you know mental wellness and happiness a
lot of these people are coming from
you know from from solid backgrounds
from okay upbringings but the adversity
that you that you went through
and the emotional strifes that you went
through i think it's just inspiring that
you're channeling that towards helping
others
and so in the last few minutes that we
have i'd love to to learn about
the happiness factor and what you're
doing with that startup because you
decided to leave
the traditional tech world and the
positions that you've held before
with human resources and now you've
transitioned into this startup so talk
to me about that
yeah so i started my startup happiness
practice three years ago
and that time when i started even though
i have some very good mentors like my
some of my ex vps joined some of the
very
famous fortune 500 people are on my
board as well as quite a few doctors and
nlp practitioners and hypnotherapists
and so initially when i started
i had a few mentors and they told me who
will pay for happiness
right people think happiness could come
free and now everyone tells me you are
in the right place right time
so i think i saw it much before others
did right so that time i started and
then i wanted to develop my app that
time when i started and but still like
i did my research on headspace on calm
and all others available
and i found uh what's uh not working
because many of my friends the companies
buy those apps for them but they don't
use it because they don't find it
interesting enough
so i decided to do a different uh pro
like way so i made it more gamified and
more interesting and more targeted
towards the millennials
and it's i made sure that all the
background is very happy
and people can relate to it and so right
now it's still getting developed and
uh app is just a very small path so i'm
doing the whole ecosystem
so we have coaches on site where we
coach people on anxiety on
um on whatever problem they come up with
because first session is always free
that's called the strategy session
where we decide if it's a good fit for
us or them or not if not
i'll refer them for to someone else if
it's a good fit then we will take it on
on happiness factors and either it will
be me or someone else who will
be coaching them we also do lots of
keynotes at different companies actually
i did one
on mental health at servicenow just two
days ago
which went pretty well and i'm sure i'll
be called back to do another bigger
session because many people were
talking about that then i do lots of
workshops and trainings right now
everything is of course on zoom but
i love to do uh in person and i have
done like right from one day to half day
to two days at different
companies and mostly high tech because
that's my background
but you know mental health is
universally applicable it doesn't have
to be limited to high tech and i and i
also did some talks for
some high schools and some um colleges
here too and i got called to do one at
uh
the cupertino high but uh it got
postponed because of
kovit again and they wanted they were
saying that mental health is so
important for these teenagers who are
working so hard to get
into a good school and the stress
sometimes gets to them right
so how to manage that and not get angry
so we are creating a whole emotional
wellness ecosystem
a one-stop shop for everything emotional
wellness
and we are doing it without the use of
drugs alcohol or marijuana
so that's my tagline that we not just
help you get happiness but sustain it
without drugs alcohol or marijuana
and we are combining the eastern
methodologies of
ayurveda yoga vedic teachings sanatana
and with the western psychology
hypnotherapy
in neurolinguistic programming mer
energy healing
and creating unique solutions which not
just take care of the symptoms of mental
health issues but they get rid of the
root cause
so that people can live a happy and
fulfilled
life for as long as they want anita
thank you for this thank you for the
wonderful work that you're doing and for
and for helping others around the world
before we leave uh i want to thank you
for being so generous with your time as
well
and i'd love to hear three words that
you would use to describe yourself
i would say unstoppable resilient
confident
tiny beam of light
i love that i love that thank you very
very much stay safe and stealthy and i
look forward to maintaining in touch
thank you for everything
thank you so much have a great evening
you too